[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
In today's video,
we're going to be taking a look
at the properties of magnetic
metals and the magnets themselves
when you heat them up
or even melt them down.
[Music]
We've got a couple of magnets,
a bar of mild steel, and a furnace,
and we want to see what happens
if we start combining these together.
The magnets of course right now
are attracted to the bar of steel,
but we want to see what happens
if we start heating these things up.
If we get our steel
glowing orange hot,
will it still be
attracted to the magnets?
If we get our magnets
glowing orange hot,
will they still be
attracted to the steel?
And after we do all of those things,
we might just try melting
some of these down,
the steel and the magnets,
until they're completely liquid,
and see how that
affects the magnetism.
Here's the basic idea.
We'll try heating up
a piece of steel,
and seeing how long it retains
its magnetic properties.
We'll then try heating up
the magnets themselves,
and see how well they retain
their magnetic properties.
Finally, we'll try
melting down both,
and seeing how they
interact with each other.
First up, we're gonna fire up our furnace,
put our bar of steel down inside,
so one end of it gets super glowing hot.
We're going to pull that out,
and see if it is still attracted
to either of our magnets.
One end of our steel bar
is now glowing orange hot,
and this furnace gets
up to about 2000 degrees.
So let's see how magnetic
a 2000 degree bar mild steel is.
So in theory, at about 1400
degrees, it stops being magnetic.
Pretty much nothing
on the ceramic magnet.
Our steel was glowing orange hot,
and at that point,
it was no longer attracted
to either of our magnets.
The ceramic magnet
isn't all that strong,
so it shouldn't take
that much loss of magnetism
for it to not stick to that.
But the silvery neodymium
magnet is very powerful.
That thing has a lot of pull strength,
and that had no attraction to the steel.
At approximately 1420 degrees Fahrenheit,
mild carbon steel is supposed
to lose all of his magnetism,
and this bar was well
above that temperature,
so it doesn't really surprise me
that it got to the point where
it wasn't attracted to the magnets.
In theory, the steel also has
to cool down to about 500 Degrees
before it regains that
attraction to magnetism
after it's been heated up that high.
So now, I want to try the reverse.
I want to see what happens
if we heat our magnets up,
to see if they stop
being attracted to the steel.
[Music]
Oh!
And it's shattering immediately.
Well, that didn't last long.
That just exploded into pieces.
So, now we know that
ceramic or ferrite magnets
really don't like to be heated up.
That's just...
Gone.
I got to say that
I know these are pieces.
and so, they're not going to have
as much directional magnetic charge,
but even just being
in there for that long,
this isn't really sticking
to the tongs much at all.
But our ferrite magnet has
now had time to cool down,
and it is now doing a better
job of sticking to our tongs.
Not every piece.
That piece in particular seems quite weak.
Furnaces had just a minute to cool off.
So now, I can just re-ignite
this, and let that get nice and hot.
Now these magnets are
mostly made of neodymium.
Neodymium is atomic element number 60,
and these magnets,
while largely made of neodymium,
also contains some other metals.
Neodymium on its own has a melting
point of 1861 degrees Fahrenheit,
which is below the temperature
that our furnace gets to.
So it's possible that our whole
magnet could just melt in here.
The magnets however are an alloy,
and it could be that whatever
other metals are mixed in with it
raises the melting point,
so our magnet will be fine.
[Music]
That is one glowing-hot magnet.
Let's see if it's
attracted to our steel bar.
[Music]
Nothing.
Zero attempts to grab onto that bar.
It's not rolling with it.
It's not sticking it.
Just really zero.
Let's take this out,
and set it on a brick.
Not sticking to our tongs at all either.
Let's see if it starts sticking
as it cools down
the same way that the steel bar
starts sticking as it cool down.
While it's cooling down,
there's something else I want to try.
I got these two identical square
magnets with a couple of holes in them.
We're going to put one in the furnace,
heat it up till it's red-hot, take it out,
and then place the other
magnet right on top of it,
and see if it makes any difference
in how much magnetism this gains
back as it cools down.
One of the square magnets is
heating up in the furnace.
We've got our other square magnet,
and I want to see if it's attracted
to this first magnet we heated up.
At this point, the first neodymium
magnet we put in there is still not
being attracted to the metal at all.
So I'm curious of our fixed magnet here
will be attracted to that material,
even though it's not attracted to steel.
[Music]
That is a yes.
So the bigger magnet that
we put in first, the cylinder,
is not attracted to the metal itself.
But another magnet is
attracted to the cylinder magnet.
That makes me think we have eliminated
all of the magnetism out of this magnet,
and it may or may not come back.
Let's pull our square magnet
out of the furnace,
and let it cool down in
the presence of this magnet.
[Music]
Not attracted to the tongs at all.
Okay, currently, not attracted much.
Maybe a tiny tiny charge.
[Music]
Let's let those cool down completely.
Our magnets have now
had long enough to cool down,
and we have nothing.
There is a very slight draw.
It is really little,
but just barely feel it.
It's not enough to lift the magnet.
It's just barely enough to
feel a tiny tug of resistance.
All right. Well, let's see about
our magnets cooled down together,
a little bit to that.
Still almost nothing.
[Music]
Oh!
This magnet got ruined.
So we have really depleted
these magnets of their charge,
but a non-depleted magnet is still
very attracted to both of these.
We've got our miniature arc furnace,
which gets well hot enough
to melt pieces of steel,
and almost certainly
these magnets as well.
First, We're going to melt down
a piece of mild steel,
and see if there's any
magnetic attraction to it.
I kind of doubt it since it does seem to
lose its magnetic attraction
once it's glowing orange,
but we'll see what happens.
We'll give it a try, and we'll even
let it cool down somewhat
in the presence of a magnet, and see
if that can magnetize the steel itself.
Steel has a tendency to spark
quite a bit when it's melted
in this hot, so I am going to be
doing this with the lid on the furnace.
To do our testing, we're going to have
a magnet stuck on the end of our steel bar.
Once it's melted down,
we'll carefully remove the lid,
and see what happens if we bring
the magnet into the melted steel.
[Music]
I would say that is not
attracted to it at all.
Big surprise!
Not really a big surprise.
That was exciting.
All right, that is starting to cool down,
and I'm just leaving this magnet near it.
It could be that the heat from the molten
steel is just going to ruin the magnet.
Oh-oh.
Oh, I think the heat is winning.
My magnet just slid
right off of my steel bar.
I think my magnet has
lost its magnetic charge.
[Music]
Steel has just really solidly
attached itself to our fire brick here.
That is a new still
powerfully magnetic magnet.
I'm going to take our chunk
of steel, let it cool down
in the water right next to that magnet.
Chunk of steel cooled
down next to a magnet,
it already ruined the magnetism
of the first magnet,
cool down even further in
the presence of a second magnet.
Has it gained any magnetic
properties of its own?
[Music]
I'm gonna say not so much.
Well, let's move on.
Let's see what happens if we
just melt down a magnet.
[Music]
Well, that is a super bright, mag--
Holy cow!
That is giving off a lot of light.
Like a lot.
The inside is molten.
Might've ruined my screwdriver.
Oh Jesus!
[Music]
I think it was about
1400 degrees Fahrenheit,
and this was definitely getting
hot enough to melt the steel,
which melted about
2500 degrees Fahrenheit,
but the magnets were not
melting as easily as the steel.
So, something about the alloy
of the composition clearly
melts at a fairly high temperature.
As a final test, I want to
see what happens if I try
and melt down this ceramic magnet.
[Music]
There is some melted ferrite magnet.
Cooled down fairly quickly.
It doesn't like to stay liquid, and kind
of hard to direct the arc right at it,
because as it heats up,
like it did in the other furnace,
it just kind of shatters and goes everywhere.
So, it doesn't like to stay in one
place to be heat it up nicely,
but it does melt,
and like all the other magnets
we've tested, as it melts,
it really loses all of its magnetic power.
No longer attracted to steel.
Melting metal and magnets
really does seem to ruin
the magnetism that they have in them.
The magnets stop being magnetic
when you heat them up too much,
and they don't get it
back after they cool down.
Heating up steel, while it's over that
mark of about 1400 degrees Fahrenheit,
it does lose all of its magnetic charge,
but when the steel cools down,
it does become magnetic again.
Melting steel down into a little blob.
I was hoping that we would be able to
put a magnetic field around the steel,
but in putting the magnet
close to the liquid steel,
the magnet actually heated up so much
that it lost all of its magnetic charge,
and it's no longer attracted
to that piece of steel
or any other metal.
It's just not a magnet anymore.
It's just a block of was magnet.
I know what to call that.
Maybe someday in the future,
we'll try melting down steel again,
and letting it cool down in the
presence of a powerful electromagnet,
which shouldn't have its
field ruined by the heat.
Guys, that's not all there is to see.
That box up at the top will
transport you directly to our last video,
and you can go check that out.
The box at the bottom will
show you what YouTube thinks
you need to be watching next.
This bomb here in the middle
with subscribe you to the channel,
so you never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.